16
free throws to three oh
that's no charge that is going to be a
charge should be a charge
it is a charge mo wagner got in his play
and that took some courage by
wagner yeah moe that that's a good play
whoo that yeah
i think it's actually a block it was a
block and he leaned in too
see how he leaned with his left shoulder
and met him there
let's see if they challenged my
challenge didn't win
yeah they're going to challenge it i
think they uh watch out
[Applause]
giannis and mo having some words
can get under your skin within seconds
but if you're you're the bucks
and you're honest you cannot no risk
anything
i mean oh is that a headbutt
wait a second oh what no he's got he's
digging a toss oh my gosh that's not
good
there's gonna be a whole bunch of
technical fouls here
oh jeez the officials
james williams brian forte jt or we've
got a challenge we're gonna have a
review
this could be interesting we could have
an ejection
the milwaukee head coach is challenging
the offensive
call charged in number 34
but that play is now under review
in addition they will be reviewing video
for any
qualification after the dead boss
coach boot he jumped right in there and
it was one of those things
you know he couldn't prevent it it was
too late
that it was an obvious flagrant too
defined as unnecessary in excessive
contact
i mean that that is clearly the case of
that
mo wagner one of the great agitators
instigators in the game he's one of
those guys that you love to have him on
your team
you hate when you play against him he's
the guy at the schoolyard man
that you know when he's in the game
someone's getting hurt you know
like you know he's going to hit you with
an elbow with knee or whatever it is
he's all over the place and and i say
this
you know what with with giannis you've
got so much more to play for yeah right
i mean how much more in this game were
you really gonna play